you've heard of actors going method for
their roles and while we often think of
performers enduring emotional hardships
sometimes going method just means
learning a musical instrument or two or
more that can't be so hard right stick
around to find out number one not just
Wednesday but every day that's how often
you might guess that actor Jenna Ortega
had to practice while preparing for her
role in Wednesday although Jenna only
had a few months between being cast in
the role and shooting the show she
picked up the basics of cello enough to
provide a visual image of cello being
played for the role Ortega said that her
cello training began roughly two months
before shooting for Wednesday started
Wednesday plays the cello a few times
throughout the series in the few months
before filming Ortega learn to play box
Cello Suite number one and you might
notice that this is what the action of
her playing shows even though a
different song is playing on screen I
don't really feel better number two you
might assume that the piano close-ups
and La La Land are played by a jazz
piano double but actually you're seeing
Ryan Gosling playing that piano live any
guesses which other actors learn to play
the piano we'll get to it soon while the
recording we hear features pianist Randy
Kerber Ryan actually learned to do all
of that keyboard work for the role he
said I had to play city of stars for six
months for hours every day Ryan also
added that he felt unsure of himself
during the time saying every time I
tried to have a conversation with
someone during that rehearsal period I
felt like Bambi on ice it was really one
of the most fulfilling uh you know
pre-production periods I I've ever had
number three he might have already been
a star but you might say Bradley Cooper
was a star reborn after this film the
actor prepared for his role with six
months of intense guitar and piano
lessons as well as a year and a half of
vocal training all of this was to make
sure he got singer Jackson Main's voice
just right his co-star Lady Gaga was the
one who convinced Bradley to sing live
during filming saying she couldn't stand
watching movies where it's all obvious
an actor is lip syncing Bradley was
thankful for her pushing him into the
challenge saying because she's so
confident and supportive I felt pretty
comfortable once I got there it gave me
the guts to go out number four no piano
no problem Tara Edgerton had never
played piano before approaching his role
for Rocket Man where he took lessons
from Michael L Roberts to get into Elton
John's playing style according to
Roberts Taryn did all the singing
himself and much of the playing with
only a few parts dubbed over later
Robert said Taryn was playing for real
in the Crocodile Rock Your Song and
Benny and the Jet scenes Taryn even
became friends with Elton John during
filming number five imagine you were
going to play a musical icon but have no
musical experience sounds daunting right
this is how actor Rami Malek began his
journey when he was asked to play the
role of Freddie Mercury in Bohemian
Rhapsody the actor was determined not to
fake his piano playing so he started at
the beginning and learned the intro to
the verse of the song Bohemian Rhapsody
the actor said there were moments when I
thought this is not my bag I don't think
I'm going to be able to do this part of
it but the actor managed to pull through
and even won an Oscar number 6. Benedict
Cumberbatch took violin lessons to
better portray his character his teacher
noted that Cumberbatch was a quick study
and picked up her teachings faster than
she had originally hoped it was shared
that Benedict stayed back to practice
when everyone had gone home for the
night The Story Goes that a cleaner
walked into the room with a bucket in
her hand and instantly backed out
apologizing Cumberbatch responded with
an apology of his own for using the room
longer than expected number 7. Christian
Bale shared that he actually learned how
to play the drums in just two weeks for
his role in The Big Short he explained
yes yes it was a wonderful crash course
in double kick drum Bale shared that his
character Michael burry played drums to
heavy metal music to unwind when not
staring for hours at numbers on computer
screens number 8. walking the line is
harder than you might think this film's
acting Duo are rumored to have nearly
quit over the difficulty of learning to
sing and playing the guitar at the same
time but Joaquin and Rhys were in good
hands their teacher kit Alderson taught
them to play autoharp and guitar as they
prepared for their roles and their vocal
coach Roger love helped them pull
through the Big Challenge number nine
yolai he who did you know he's a trained
yodler that's right Tom Hiddleston
learned to yodel for his role in I Saw
The Light Only Lovers Left Alive not to
mention Tom moved to Nashville and lived
with singer-songwriter Rodney crawwell
for five weeks so that he could practice
Hank Williams's songs and learn to get
the country singer's Style Just Right
Tom learned to yodel and also learned to
play wait for it piano guitar violin and
the loot number 10 not his Tempo you
know the line while Whiplash actor Miles
Teller might have already had some
experience on the drums he had to learn
a new much more intense style of jazz
drumming for this film it was no easy
task miles took drum lessons for four
hours a day three times a week he did so
much training that he even developed
blisters from the intense playing style
number 11 two actor musicians one movie
you bet for their roles in The Talented
Mr Ripley Matt Damon and Jude Law both
took up lessons for their instruments
Matt learned to play the piano and Jude
learned to play saxophone while Matt's
piano training helped him to play all
the proper fingering the music we hear
is actually played by the composers of
the soundtrack for the film number 12.
if you've ever heard of Charlie Chaplin
you might have heard that he always
carried his violin around with him and
he was not afraid to play it so it seems
natural that when preparing for the role
of Charlie Chaplin after Robert Downey
Jr did the same but Robert didn't just
carry the instrument around he also took
lessons on how to play it and played it
left-handed this is very unusual but
it's how Charlie played his violin
Robert and his teacher were up to the
challenge number 13 you have probably
never heard of this band its members are
Rachel Weiss and actually that's it the
actress's role in the film The Brothers
Bloom called for her character to play
on not just the accordion but the violin
guitar and banjo for one scene what's
more she had to do it all in the space
of about 10 minutes Rachel had lessons
on all four instruments but we don't
know if the music you hear in the film
is actually being played by the actress
you might say that the accuracy of her
fingering on each instrument at least
gives a good impression though number
14. have you ever found yourself singing
a song out of your comfort zone Kyra
nightly has the Begin Again actor
undertook lessons in both singing and
playing guitar for her role as the
singer-songwriter Greta James even
though Kira took guitar lessons from her
husband she still said that she felt out
of her comfort zone and even ruled out a
music career it wasn't all bad though as
the film's song Lost Stars was nominated
for an Oscar piano is about all he had
left to do you probably have seen Adrian
Brody playing a piano virtuoso in Roman
polanski's film The Pianist to prepare
for the role Roman had Adrian practice
piano for a hefty four hours a day while
the this might have been method acting
enough for some Brody decided to take it
a few steps further leaving his longtime
girlfriend giving up his apartment
selling his car starving himself and
living in solitary confinement in a
foreign country but he was the youngest
person at the time to win an Oscar as a
result number 16 he was a busy guy you
might be intimidated by the idea of
shooting a feature film while learning
an instrument for another film but not
Samuel L Jackson who said he took six or
seven months to learn to play guitar for
his role as the blues singer Lazarus in
Black Snake Moan and while he was
learning the instrument he was also
shooting Snakes on a Plane we can't
believe the commitment these actors made
to their roles and the talent and skill
they've displayed through their musical
performances what are some of your
favorite on-screen musical moments let
us know in the comments